olá mundo votar
muito obrigada por estarem presentes
muito obrigado a organização para
realizar um evento tão importante
consiste na partilha de ideias e vai
inflar os precisamente sobre a partilha
de ideias até o local do quadro da
corporação é o que está elevado de tudo
o que nós construímos nas cidades a
nível familiar a nível local
no nosso país a nível global
nós conseguimos comprar e construir o
que temos hoje nós temos que conseguir
comunicar e esta capacidade de nos
comunicarmos com os outros que faz com
que nós consigamos de fato construir o
nosso texto e realizarmos densidade ao
longo da história são as opiniões das
nações são as opiniões que sempre
divergiram a fossem as religiosas e
ideologias que temos fizeram as pessoas
entrar em conflito mas ao mesmo tempo
nós tínhamos e tentamos desenvolver as
nossas qualidades que nos permitem
encontrar pontos de encontro de forma
diplomática e conseguimos construir a
sociedade
mas o que acontece atualmente é que essa
atualização que sempre foi resistindo ao
longo da história a nível das menções
hoje estrapolou para o nível pessoal
todos nós hoje temos opiniões muito
unidas disse amos como se fossem a
melhor e única opinião certa quem é que
já presenciou até já participou numa
qualquer conversa facebook cara a cara
seja como for em que as pessoas entram
em conflito com o tipo mais trivial são
desagradáveis tão sensíveis quem já
presenciou
olhem a volta a isto é muito preocupante
só uma pessoa que não presenciou um fato
preocupante e só pode significar alguma
coisa nós não estamos escutaram os
outros nós estamos a executar e do tempo
não estamos a comunicar nós pensarmos
bem
as opiniões que nós temos não fomos nós
que inventamos dependendo do local onde
nós temos um momento histórico da
cultura dominante
nós adotamos pacote de idéias que estão
disponíveis chegam até nós e tudo -
portistas
eu defendo estas ideias e depois vemos
uns com os outros para defender a nossa
razão está a acontecer esta organização
está a acontecer a nível individual
acontece muito também dividiu os poderão
utilizar as tecnologias em esconderam
por trás delas
é fato notório mas também está
demonstrado que nós nos comunicamos
muito mais por telemóvel uns com os
outros mesmo com as pessoas mais
próximas do cara a cara e isso tem um
efeito logo muito negativo porque o
outro ser humano está do lado de lá já
não é um ser humano e nós não vemos o
brilho nos olhos do lado lá a foto do
filme não abrirem os olhos
então entendemos e sentir menos simpatia
e então aonde estamos nos atacar
isso também porque porque nós
valorizamos este momento o conteúdo das
nossas mensagens todas as comunicações
tem esta estrutura existe o conteúdo eo
processo de comunicação e nós temos
vindo a falhar nas duas e o que nós
podemos fazer nós podemos melhorar as
duas coisas em primeiro lugar de novo
conteúdo
ao invés de defenderem esse pacote de
idéias que achamos que são certos e que
temos de admitir não é possível basta
ter uns instigarem pactual para perceber
que cada um de nós não tem tempo mesmo
até chegar a velhinha para saber tudo o
que se passa num debater a certeza que
estes a opinião já estão aqui os
resultados depois não exata do que disse
não é possível então que nós devemos
começar por fazer é melhorar o conteúdo
das nossas opiniões é sempre uma coisa
que podemos fazer depois passamos ao
processo
nós vamos participar das conversas
presumindo que estas opiniões que nós
temos chegaram hoje tem nós mulheres por
para porque do nosso ano passado há
cinco anos as nossas opiniões multaram
certo nós temos em constante evolução
mas se nós estivermos conscientes que
esse processo acontece então nós vamos
ap a mente colocar em causa as nossas
opiniões e essa é a primeira sugestão
que eu trago hoje para partilhar
convosco
nós devemos sempre estar dispostos a
confrontar nos com as opiniões
diferentes para possivelmente perceber
se aquilo que nós pensamos hoje vai de
acordo com os nossos valores
fundamentais
estamos a ter atitude certa em depois
mais é que as nossas opiniões tão
elevado de tudo que nós fazemos na vida
das nossas opiniões é que vão decidir
que nós vamos começar com quem vamos
casar onde vamos morar profissão vamos
ter importância de nossas opiniões não
forem constantemente confrontado de
renovadas com ideias novas
elas vão ser limitadas esses nossas
opiniões vão ser limitadas estão as
opiniões que estão na base de tudo que
nós fazemos na nossa vida então também
nossa existência
vai ser limitada
nós precisamos uma vida um livro
se nós queremos ter uma vida plena e
autêntica então nós devemos praticar
este exercício tem uma comunicação
eficaz 21 desde logo que nós vamos ter
de estar que tudo dê em vez de seguirmos
aquilo que os outros nos entregam um
concerto em seguir o caminho mais comum
vamos questionar vamos pôr em causa
aquilo que nós pensamos para tentar ser
melhores e mais livres dessa forma
construir uma vida melhor e mais feliz
o processo de comunicação por além do
conteúdo tem então é parte formal
existe uma mensagem que vai passar de
edificado do emissor para o setor
yang estão responsáveis da mesma forma
para o resultado final da mensagem há
uma intenção que o emissor vai passar e
depois dependendo de muitos fatores e do
que acontece em maio da mensagem é a
mensagem pode ser adulterada é o que nós
chamamos ruído como e ver tudo aquilo
podem influenciar a mensagem que do
turbo e ela pode chegar ao ponto de ser
invertida quando chega ao lado a
excluído potter é fundamento tudo
constituindo das barreiras da
comunicação
as barreiras podem ser objetivos desde
logo o link estiver muito barulho nos
conscientizou victor não conseguiu se
comunicar por exemplo uma uma linguagem
uma linguagem pobre se não conhecermos
as palavras o significado não
conseguimos comunicar solar de forma
ambígua quando não conhecemos bem o
assunto estamos a falar mas mesmo assim
defendemos também não conseguindo
despistar o pagamento queremos dizer ou
o posto está essa informação sei tanto
sobre isto
despeje é minha formação e meu
conhecimento sobre os outros
este constitui também uma barreira mas
de cumprir ocupa o facto são as
barreiras emocionais é o que chama de
cuidar em um sinal e este é que é o que
nós podemos controlar o que é do nosso
tempo deixe de controlar o seu estado e
estas barreiras têm vindo a trabalhar a
nossa vida diária
nós estamos a perder a capacidade de
comunicar e de curar curto quando a
nossa atitude
por exemplo a tristeza raiva ansiedade
estresse estas que são estão a criar os
principais que ocupam o nosso dia a dia
quando não as atitudes já está negativa
de alguma forma eu não estou preparada
nem um livro para receber a mensagem do
outro e ciência ignorância o medo das
mensagens novas
alguém está a dizer uma coisa que eu
nunca ouvi é novo não quer tenho medo é
uma barreira
o narcisismo o ego acho que já sei tudo
se o partido para uma conversa chat já
sei tudo em tão pouco está dizendo à
imprensa para nada porque eu não estou
disposta a mudar de ideias e o
preconceito preconceitos estereótipos
são já hoje são impedimentos muito forte
para a evolução das nossas ideias e
quando alguém está a falar e eu já estou
encaixar essa pessoa a dentro de um
estereótipo então eu já estou julgar
tudo que ela diz de outra forma de
comunicação eficaz pois um desde logo
que tanto já sabemos já temos
consciência
devemos melhorar o conteúdo das nossas
opiniões mas depois também temos
consciência destas barreiras começa por
termos esta esta capacidade de saber que
nós podemos melhorar o que está na nossa
mão efetivamente fazê lo e devemos
partir para as conversas não é para
confrontar o outro com a nossa razão mas
por encontrarmos o ponto de encontro há
sempre pontos em que nós conseguimos
estar de acordo com os portistas daí as
pessoas sim entendo perfeitamente
compreendido ness e depois contra
argumentar mas só assim é que podemos
conseguir
e daí as idéias novas melhorá-las ver se
devemos determinar ou até síndicos
nossas idéias com maior convicção
daquela conversa as nossas ideias saem
reforçadas também é muito importante
conseguirmos que este processo seja
feito com conexão com as peças de
comunicação eficaz são devastadoras
porque para lá em seu entendimento no
nosso dia-a-dia certeza que toda a gente
tem não entende de em casa no facebook
com os amigos mal entendidos é o prato
do dia mas depois pode ser muito pior
porque nós não conseguimos fazer nos
escutar
vamos ficar frustrados quando o torna
uma pessoa frustrada e hoje já parte
para as próximas conversações de
presumir frustrada ea frustração acaba
por ter um cansaço em atraso isolamento
social não consegue se comunicar é uma
das maiores formas de isolamento social
da atualidade
as pessoas não sentem compreendidas de
nenhum contacto com as pessoas mesmo com
as mais próximas as relações ficam
prejudicadas no exterior tudo podem
mesmo ser destruídas
a boa notícia é que existem técnicas
a maior parte já são conhecidas todos
nós podemos aprender algumas técnicas
para comunicar melhor porque o processo
de comunicação seja mais saudável
há uma que é básica e estas criar e
falta mais atualmente que serão educados
nós fomos educados mesmo depois não
tinham os outros grandes competências
a portuguesa já não evitaram muitos
conflitos porque tem sempre as conversas
com esta técnica seria do caso
depois olhar nos olhos mostra que
estamos a prestar atenção a pessoa
conseguir melhor do que ela está sem
antes de assinar com a cabeça é uma
técnica que eu não gosto muito é falsa a
equipe sinta tão visto que já tentou
entender mas mostra mostra interesse da
nossa parte seja uns breves programa mas
as pessoas fazerem as perguntas para
desenvolver na conversa é de forma que
ela perceba que sua opinião conta e
nuclear nisa que os pensamentos que o
salton façam exercício depois que nós
não temos aqui tento experimento escutar
alguém atrevimento durante alguns
minutos e contém o número de vezes que
tenha mentido e às vezes faltam por
interromper a pessoa e não resistimos em
contexto de uma coisa que é fã
eu já estou à espera que a pessoa acaba
de falar que é por eu depois de
demonstrar minha informação reunida é
tão inteligentes então a partir de certo
ponto eu deixei o vício
então se deixem de escutar eu já estou
nessa conversa não estamos a comunicar
mas eu cumpri ocupa de facto são os
princípios nós não utilizamos é que
essas técnicas podem surpreender e podem
ser estimuladas mas os princípios os
princípios de uma comunicação eficaz tem
que partir de nós
parte da nossa essência de nossas
verdades nós diremos partes para cada
conversa para toda a comunicação com
humildade está na base de tudo
nós devemos começar uma conversa sempre
presente que temos algo a aprender
nós temos sempre a aprender ea prova é
que há um ano atrás não pensávamos
compensamos hoje então e reassumir sua
preciso que não sabemos alguma coisa
porque o histórico até mais credível
todas as coisas que vivemos ficamos mais
ou menos ea chave essencial para a
comunicação é saber escutar
chama se escutar queria uma coisa todos
podemos treinar
se nós não estivermos executar de facto
nós não temos a aprender nada de novo
então estamos a pressionar as nossas
opiniões então as nossas opiniões são
limitadas
a seguir é limitada não haver um
entendimento e só é possível sim mas
também para ficar num exemplo tia o que
empatia empatia com as filas nos colocar
no lugar do outro muito bem mas não é
simples esta frase eu tenho a sensação
que atualmente ele tem uma forma um
bocadinho desviada sentido colocar no
lugar do outro significa que estou
escutar o que a pessoa está a dizer mas
não estou já a julgar com os meus
princípios e com as minhas ideias
eu tenho escutado elemento que a pessoa
está a dizer com os olhos dela eu tô ver
através da sua visão eu estou a sentir
através de seu coração eu tenho mesmo
que tentar perceber como é que a
experiência é para aquela pessoa porque
minha experiência é outra então a minha
experiência e só vai enriquecer se eu
consegui primeira experiência do outro
mais importantes é também estarão os
plenamente na conversa não estar nas
condições se estamos aqui conversar e eu
estou no telemóvel gostou e ator lógico
que não estou plenamente naquela
conversa para além de mais uma vez não
está a aprender nada e tudo aqui é o
processo
eu estou a ser respeitosa
depois não nos sentirmos superiores este
é outro dos problemas da atualidade que
nós hoje com a internet as chamas que
recebemos tudo porque só isso aí nós
hoje temos tudo então porque nos traz
conversas mais uma vez com uma
superioridade pode ser ao nível do
conhecimento achar que eu sei mais do
que os outros ou ainda pior
a superioridade moral achar que eu já vi
um e tanto que agora estou acima dos
outros só que o chargista moralmente a
sina de alguém em 5 indiretamente que
outro estava mais 900 respeitoso a
influenciar negativamente a conversa e
voltamos ao mesmo esquema e no final
quem sai prejudicado são os nós para
conseguirmos fazer isto tudo devemos
partir de um outro princípio básico que
aprenderam desafiar com os outros
quando nós olhamos para as outras
pessoas nos olhos que conhecemos são
seres humanos como nós
cada pessoa enfim
é um mundo é o seu mundo de idéias são
tuas confundiam idades são os com
sentimentos como nós e pessoas que
também estão aqui atentar se fluids
prestação mas sim para entrar nesta por
nós são papéis na sociedade
tentamos tentar apreciar mais os outros
iriam partir logo para as conversas
diminuímos porque isso que nós fizemos
mesmo sempre ele então eu tenho alguma
questão para foi que eu estou dizendo
que dinho já estamos neste momento
conscientes de que todos nós podemos
melhorar o nosso processo de comunicação
e podemos melhorar o conteúdo da nossa
conexão e vamos tentar lançar mão agora
de todas estas coisas que falamos de
todos estes exemplos e técnicas e
princípios e dá nos questionar o mundo
hoje estivéssemos de fato comunicar toda
a gente concorda que não têm de
comunicar que esta esta técnica de
comunicação de falar não é uma conversa
falar é uma conversa e nós não estamos
mais do lado de disputar em si não
estamos com um está no estado em que
está a caminhar para melhor como é que
seria o mundo nós tivemos que aplicar em
transição e difícil
a melhor mensagem do mundo e então que
eu fiz eu pensei eu vou olhar a minha
volta e vou escolher uma mensagem que
acha que é de fato muito importantes e
penso que vocês procuram gostar eu quero
fazer algumas perguntas primeiro é que a
audiência se perguntar é vocês gostariam
de ouvir alguma mensagem que nos
transmite se uma idéia simples que esta
silva de ser mudando algumas coisas nos
nossos hábitos diários sem estar mais
tempo sem gastar mais dinheiro vendendo
alguns hábitos na nossa vida conseguimos
por exemplo melhorar a nossa seu uso
quem é que gostaria de ouvir muita gente
é preocupada com a ser muito bem quem é
que aqui se importa também ficam com os
problemas da fome no mundo
é tarde os outros com compaixão e
respeito quem é que acha que devemos em
estender o respeito aos restantes
animais à venda a gente olhava o tamanho
da jean brasileiro no ar
estas são coisas que nos preocupam de
facto de as mensagens estão em mostrar
que nós estamos a exportar
eu fiz uma pequena compilação e que lhes
peço vos vamos pensar enfim alguns fatos
rapidamente nas peças que tenham aquela
os princípios do que nós falamos de
saúde e cinco de ser que as evidências
científicas apontam para que uma
alimentação de base digital pode trazer
benefícios para a nossa seu uso para um
indício pode mesmo prevenir doenças
graves como a obesidade e doença
oncológica e silvos decerto ordens do
juiz início de vários países
em nossa é a nossa direcção geral da
saúde portuguesa já lançaram guias sobre
a alimentação estritamente digital e que
afirmo é propriá da por todos os
indivíduos e silva dizer que a
organização mundial de saúde já diz que
a carne vermelha é considerada
provavelmente cristina gênica e carne
processada fica ao lado do parque do
bonito com cristina gênica mensagem está
aí será que nós temos estado a escutar
igualmente a natureza
o mesmo fato a mesma mudança na nossa
vida que nós podemos considerar que
fazer aquilo que está na nossa
disponibilidade se conseguimos ou não
mas uma assim consigamos nós podemos ao
mesmo tempo ajudar o planeta porto é
precisamente é parte da produção dos
animais a produção intensiva estacas
podem pesquisar porque são assuntos
muito complexos mas que está a
contribuir para o aquecimento global
igualmente o problema da forma no mundo
a maior parte das plantações no mundo
são feitas para alimentar gado que
depois vão ser o nosso jantar mas é esse
hectares
essa grande parte do mundo se forem
cultivadas com filiais por alimentar as
pessoas nós podemos matar a fome de
milhões de pessoas ao invés time
os animais mas ao mesmo tempo se nós
mudarmos a nossa alimentação também
podemos ganhar mas é uma valia da
tremenda que nós não sabemos por que não
procuramos vilar tremenda de receitas
podemos criar as nossas tradicionais
portugueses podemos aprender muito
receitas novas mas depois também podemos
aumentar nosso circo compaixão aos
restantes animais samsung que saltou e
ok
hoje sabemos são os fatos nós sabemos
que os animais são detentores da mesma
consistência do que nós quer dizer que
elas conseguem experience ar funções ter
intenções conseguem sentir as coisas
como nós e fez um deles é o indivíduo e
o que nós fazemos são milhares de
milhões que de um acidente e primeiras
coisas tal como as três doenças mas
também porque atualmente cada vez mais
pessoas pensa conhecem pelo menos a
maioria das casas não campeão aqui todas
escolhi algumas que cada vez mais
pessoas estão atentas a escutar a
mensagem estão a fazer sua parte para
melhorar o mundo
então o convite que o estrago é um
convite muito cincos se nós temos o
poder de melhorar um dos está na nossa
não então nós devemos primeiro aprender
e praticar a comunicação eficaz
desde logo questionando o conteúdo será
que as nossas opiniões estão de acordo
com os nossos valores fundamentais será
que não estamos a praticar é que o que
nos vai ter essa felicidade plena e
depois aprender a fazer o processo
porque imaginem eu tenho a minha
mensagem do mundo mas temos que tentar
passar essa mensagem de forma decisiva a
com superioridade moral eu aposto que
ninguém está disposto a ouvir porque
ninguém está disposto nem é obrigado a
ouvir mais simples o total houve também
foi o impacto e conceitos estiveram
humildade intelectual de dizer deixem
impressionar no então nós vamos poder
ser mais livres de escolhas que vão de
facto de encontros com este mundo
maravilhoso de compaixão por todos e ele
nos convida a fazer
todos os dias nas nossas vidas obrigada